qu'est-ce que c'est deux lieux ont en
commun oui je sais dis comme ça c'est
très très dur de deviner quoi que en
vrai avec le titre peut-être que c'est
plus simple ce sont tous les deux des
frontières entre deux pays dans cette
vidéo on va donc explorer ensemble les
10 frontières les plus spectaculaires du
monde un sujet un petit peu plus léger
que les dernières vidéos qu'on a pu
faire sur la chaîne mais vous allez le
voir c'est passionnant et en plus on va
pas mal voyager et si vous le voulez
bien on va commencer ensemble avec les
plus belles frontières naturelles parce
que vous en conviendrez une cascade
c'est quand même un peu plus sympa que
des barbelés ou des murs pour délimiter
deux pays saviez-vous que les deux plus
belles cascades du monde sont aussi des
frontières entre deux pays c'est
notamment le cas de la frontière qui
sépare le Brésil et l'Argentine où l'on
peut retrouver les chutes d'Iguazu
d'ailleurs les touristes tamponne
généralement deux fois leur passeport en
allant les visiter et ce ne sont pas les
deux seuls pays à avoir cette chance la
Zambie et le Zimbabwe en Afrique sont
eux aussi à un endroit
séparer par l'une des chutes d'eau les
plus impressionnantes du monde j'ai
nommé les chutes Victoria alors
certaines frontières comme celle-ci sont
totalement naturelles mais certaines
fois bien qu'elle soit naturelle et bien
les États ont tenu à les matérialiser
regardez par exemple cette frontière
entre la Norvège et la Suède les sapins
ont été en fait rasés sur toute une
bande sur plusieurs kilomètres de long
pour bien créer une forme de
délimitation et ça donne d'ailleurs une
perspective et une image assez étonnante
remarquée peut-être qu'il vaut mieux sac
un mur puisque des murs il en existe des
dizaines dans le monde pour séparer deux
pays on en compte près de 70 et c'est
d'ailleurs dix fois plus qu'en 1989
depuis la chute du mur de Berlin et mis
bout à bout tous ces murs de frontières
représentent près de 40000 km de long
soit presque exactement la circonférence
de la Terre alors bien souvent dans ces
cas là c'est parce que l'un des deux
pays veut éviter des migrations
illégales venant d'un autre pays souvent
plus pauvre le plus long par exemple il
est entre l'Inde et le Bangladesh avec
une longueur de près de 3200 km et le
plus célèbre peut-être c'est celui entre
les États-Unis et le Mexique dont la
construction a commencé en 2006 et que
Donald Trump on en avait parlé sur la
chaîne avez voulu renforcer les
Américains avaient mis des moyens
colossaux qui avaient fait beaucoup
débats à l'époque et ça donne donc des
paysages assez particuliers par exemple
sur la plage de tiruana ou le mur va
même s'allonger dans la mer d'ailleurs
quand on parle de frontière terrestre le
mot mur ça peut parfois être un abus de
langage en fait en réalité c'est souvent
des zones qui sont sécurisées et parfois
ça prend la forme d'un mur parfois d'un
grillage géant avec des piquets très
resserrés et c'est le cas d'ailleurs de
la frontière entre les États-Unis et le
Mexique ils peuvent discuter à certains
endroits de chaque côté et certains ont
même installé des balançoires vous avez
peut-être déjà vu ces images alors si
les Américains ont une frontière assez
connue mondialement aujourd'hui au sud
avec le Mexique et bien elle en a aussi
au nord mais elle est très différente la
frontière entre les Etats-Unis et le
Canada et la plus longue du monde elle
s'étend sur presque 9000 km à l'inverse
aussi sur cette frontière pas de tonnes
de briques de ciment pas de douaniers et
pas de mur entre le Canada et les
États-Unis on retrouve donc la plus
grande frontière du monde même si vous
l'aurez compris les infrastructures sont
assez faibles à l'inverse quelle est la
frontière la plus petite du monde alors
petit quiz quelle longueur pourrait-elle
faire 800 km 80 km 8 km ou encore des la
réponse d ou alors 80 mètres et bien oui
c'est la dernière réponse 80 mètres la
plus petite frontière mesure moins de
100 mètres c'est même moins que la
longueur donc d'un terrain de football
pour je vous refais pas un quiz pour
savoir où elle se situe mais elle se
trouve entre le Maroc et l'Espagne et
oui certes il y a la mer Méditerranée
entre le Maroc et l'Espagne sauf que au
nord du Maroc il existe vous le savez
peut-être des enclaves espagnol donc des
petits territoires espagnols totalement
entourés donc par le Maroc c'est des
vestiges notamment de la période
coloniale les plus connues sont Ceuta et
melilah mais il y a notamment du coup
cette toute petite frontière d'à peine
80 mètres qui sépare le Maroc de
l'enclave espagnol du rocher de Badis
aussi appelé pénium des vélos de la
gomella désolé pour l'accent
catastrophique celui une centaine de
personnes en fait habitent sur ce rocher
le tout donc bien gardé par une petite
caserne de l'armée de terre espagnole et
oui du coup c'est pas toujours connu
mais il est donc possible d'être dans
l'Union européenne sur le continent
africain et dans ces enclaves la monnaie
officielle est donc l'euro le Maroc et
l'Espagne se sépare sur ce 00 alors si
on revient maintenant sur les États-Unis
ils ont aussi une frontière très
particulière une frontière cette fois-ci
à l'ouest qu'elle partage avec la Russie
et d'ailleurs cette frontière c'est
peut-être la plus insolite du monde
comment est-ce possible et bien parce
que ça concerne l'Alaska qui est un
territoire américain que les États-Unis
ont racheté à la Russie en 1867 pour 7,2
millions de dollars à l'époque alors 7,2
millions de dollars à l'époque c'est
l'équivalent de 120 millions de dollars
aujourd'hui sont fait certaines
estimations en fait une époque où la
Russie était pas mal ruinée il y avait
donc besoin d'argent on peut dire donc
que c'était une sacrée bonne affaire à
l'époque maintenant à ce prix là on a à
peine un demi Neymar qui vient jouer
dans un club alors quand on regarde une
carte ou autre on peut se dire que non
il y a pas de frontière terrestre entre
la Russie et les États-Unis ici il y a
seulement une frontière maritime et
effectivement c'est vrai sauf quelques
jours par an et là il zoomer un petit
peu dans la carte dans le détroit de
Béring entre l'Alaska et la Russie on
aperçoit à un endroit deux petits bouts
de terre aux falaises impressionnantes
ce sont les îles géomètres l'une de ces
deux îles la Grande est appartient à la
Russie c'est superficie fait moins d'un
tiers de celle de Paris et l'autre elle
est toute petite elle est appartient aux
États-Unis ces deux îles elles sont
séparées par 3,2 km en fait ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que en hiver c'est
3,2 km ils sont totalement constitués de
glace il est donc en théorie possible de
rejoindre les deux îles à pied mais ce
que l'on ne voit pas directement sur des
cartes c'est que la grande Diomède qui
est donc russe sert de petites bases
militaires à la Russie je peux vous dire
du coup qu'aucun des 78 habitants de la
petite Diomède américaine de tente
d'aller faire une petite balade là-bas
pas envie quand on chasse l'ours si on
passe par mégarde de la frontière les
Russes nous tirent dessus en visant la
neige à nos pieds c'est ce que confiait
un habitant dans le journal
Figaro en 2013 et alors ce qui rend
cette frontière encore plus
exceptionnelle c'est ce que l'on appelle
la ligne de changement de date qui se
situe en plein milieu en fait cette
ligne c'est une ligne imaginaire qui ont
plus de changer l'heure et bien fait
aussi changer de jour pour que les dates
restent cohérentes dans le monde entier
les îles sont donc certes séparées de
seulement 3,2 km mais elles sont donc
aussi séparées de 20 ou 21h en fonction
des saisons bon et pourquoi 21h et pas
24 heures là je rentre dans les détails
ça devient un peu technique
et bien parce que les États-Unis ont
décidé de garder la petite Diomède et
l'Alaska sur le fuseau horaire
UTC moins neuf et non pas UTC -11 c'est
ce qui fait donc ce décalage quoi qu'il
en soit ça amène donc à des situations
assez étonnantes quand il est lundi 23h
sur la petite géomède aux États-Unis et
bien il est mardi 20h sur la grande
biomède alors qu'il y a donc seulement
quelques kilomètres qu'il est séparent
mais alors c'est assez fascinant faut
savoir qu'il y a des financière certes
beaucoup entre deux pays mais aussi
parfois des frontières entre trois pays
on appelle ça des tripoints ils sont
souvent marqués par des monuments parmi
les plus belles et les plus connues il y
a la triple frontière entre le Paraguay
le Brésil et l'Argentine qui sont
séparés par les rivières de Parana et
d'oiseau il y a aussi le tri-point qui
concerne la France il est situé entre la
France la Suisse et l'Allemagne autour
de la ville de Bâle et d'ailleurs
symbolisé par un monument de 15 mètres
de haut bon mais comme si c'était pas
assez il y a encore plus extraordinaire
il existe dans le monde une frontière
entre quatre pays ou plutôt d'ailleurs
faut appeler ça un quadripoint alors je
vous fais pas deviner on est parce que
là encore ça durait longtemps mais en
l'occurrence on peut le retrouver au sud
de l'Afrique entre la Zambie le Zimbabwe
le Botswana et la Namibie sur la rivière
zombies alors en réalité les géographes
les plus puristes vous diront que c'est
faux que c'est un quasi quadripoint et
effectivement ils ont raison en fait on
a deux tripoints mais qui sont très très
proches ce qui fait donc que certains
parlent de quadripoint bon par contre
une vraie frontière entre quatre pays il
y en a pas mais il y en a quand même une
entre quatre États américains c'est déjà
pas mal merci du coup aux frontières
dessinées à la règle on retrouve
l'Arizona au sud-ouest le Colorado au
nord-est le Nouveau Mexique au sud-est
et l'Utah donc au nord-ouest il est
marqué par un monument appelé le faux
corners monuments avec au milieu donc un
cercle qui vous permet d'être dans les
quatre États en même temps bon quittons
les Etats-Unis retournent en Europe il y
a une frontière dont je voulais
absolument vous parler dans cette vidéo
c'est celle entre la Belgique et les
Pays-Bas au niveau du village de Bayern
voilà en l'occurrence c'est comment
faire compliqué quand on peut faire très
simple certains parlent même de la zone
frontalière la plus complexe au monde ce
village en fait il est mis néerlandais
et mi belge il a deux noms c'est
bernassault pour la partie qui
appartient au Pays-Bas et Berg duc pour
la partie qui appartient donc à la
logique lors des discussions en fait sur
la frontière entre les deux pays donc la
Belgique et les Pays-Bas en 1843 et bien
les pays ne s'étaient pas mis d'accord
sur une frontière pour cette zone on
utilise attention des cartes qui ont été
tracées en 1198 au Moyen-Âge conséquence
il y a 22 ans que là en fait de la
partie belge belge duc dans le Berl
Nassau hollandais et il y a 8 enclaves
du bar Nassau dans Bar-le-Duc du coup
faut le dire dans la ville où les villes
d'ailleurs c'est un petit peu n'importe
quoi ce qui rend tout cas c'est étonnant
c'est que du coup on a littéralement des
maisons qui sont situées dans deux pays
ce qui est pas forcément giga pratique
mais du coup je faisais savoir la règle
pour savoir si une maison est belge ou
néerlandaise et bien c'est en fonction
du lieu où se trouve la porte d'entrée
de la maison donc là en l'occurrence
c'est indiqué très clairement sur le
numéro de la rue bon et du coup vu que
c'est déjà pas mal le bazar pour éviter
que ça le soit encore plus ils ont
littéralement tracé la frontière dans
absolument toute la ville bon deux
petites anecdotes en plus sur cette
ville après on à une autre mais il faut
savoir que certes les mairies sont bien
séparés mais le poste de police
Néerlandais se trouve en fait dans le
bâtiment de la mairie belge qui a quand
même une forme de coopération ici et si
vous voulez savoir une dernière petite
chose assez intéressante pendant le
covid le côté belge était confiné
pendant que le côté néerlandais ne
l'était pas ça a donc fait que les
habitants belges ont littéralement pu
voir leur voisin se balader
tranquillement alors qu'ils étaient à
quelques mètres l'un de l'autre bon mais
sans aller jusqu'à ce niveau de
complexité il existe en France une
situation assez insolite avec la Suisse
c'est l'hôtel arbresi un hôtel situé à
la fois en France sur la commune des
Rousses et à la fois en Suisse sur la
commune de Saint-Cergues alors comment
est-ce que c'est possible en fait la
France et la Suisse ont convenu de leur
frontières lors du traité des dates le 8
décembre 1862 mais le traité n'a été
signé officiellement que deux mois plus
tard et entre temps un certain pontu qui
possédait un terrain concerné par le
découpage et qui vivait de la
contrebande a fait construire en fait en
vitesse un bâtiment entre les deux et
les deux camps du coup la France comme
la Suisse ont refusait de céder leur
partie résultat dans certaines chambres
on peut dormir la tête en France et les
pieds en Suisse c'est alors en cas de
désaccord sur un territoire plutôt que
le couper au milieu l'une des solutions
peut-être tout simplement d'alterner à
qui il appartient c'est par exemple ce
qui se passe pour l'île des faisans qui
se situe entre la France et l'Espagne
chaque année Lille les françaises du
premier août au 31 janvier et espagnol
du 1er février au 31 juillet pour autre
info cette particularité elle est assez
unique un territoire comme ça sur lequel
deux états exercent une souveraineté
c'est ce que l'on appelle un condominium
voilà mot assez long à noter pour vous
mais vous avez un scrabble bientôt bon
en tout cas sur cette île
malheureusement vous pouvez pas la
visiter elle est interdite au public
mais ça n'a pas toujours été le cas elle
a beau faire seulement la taille d'un
terrain de foot il s'est passé des
choses assez incroyables dessus dans
l'histoire par exemple au 15e siècle il
y a notamment eu une rencontre
historique sur cette île entre le roi de
France Louis XII et le roi d'Espagne
Henri de Castille et en 1660 le Traité
des Pyrénées un traité qui a mis fin à
des décennies de guerre il a été signé
donc sur place en même temps qui était
célébré à mariage royal bon là du coup
clairement certains peuvent se demander
je sais mais c'est pertinent ou quoi de
s'embêter sur des territoires aussi
petits et forcément on peut comprendre
beaucoup mieux quand il s'agit
potentiellement de doubler la taille de
son pays c'est le cas par exemple en
Corée et oui comment finir cette vidéo
autrement qu’on abordant la frontière
entre la Corée du Nord et la Corée du
Sud c'est la frontière la plus
militarisée et la plus sécurisée au
monde depuis 1953 et la fin de la guerre
des deux Corée les deux pays sont
séparés par une zone démilitarisée de
près de 250 km de long pour 4 km de
large c'est une zone où l'activité
militaire y est interdite et pourtant
même si c'est assez contradictoire il
s'agit bel et bien de la la plus
militarisée au monde pour vous rendre
compte c'est assez hallucinant la
frontière est tout simplement surveillée
par plus d'un million de soldats et si
jamais tout cela ne suffisait pas et
bien selon différentes estimations il y
aurait près d'un million de mines qui
serait enfouis au niveau de cette
frontière à cause justement de la guerre
des deux Corée donc la seule façon de
traverser cette frontière c'est en
passant parce que l'on appelle la
joindre security un point de passage ou
des gardes sud-coréen et nord-coréen se
font face toute la journée et d'ailleurs
il y a déjà eu plusieurs rencontres
symboliques entre les chefs d'État des
deux pays ces dernières années en tout
cas pour la petite anecdote si on va
sous terre et donc sous cette frontière
et bien il y a quatre tunnels et
peut-être même plus qui ont été creusés
à la fin des années 70 par la Corée du
Nord alors dans quel but a priori dans
le but très sûrement de créer une
attaque surprise contre la Corée du Sud
alors cette attaque entre guillemets
elle a été annulée et aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs l'un des tunnels est devenu
un site touristique qu'il est possible
de visiter en passant par la Corée du
Sud mais ça vous intéresse et que vous
voulez en apprendre un petit peu plus
sur le sujet je vous conseille une autre
vidéo qu'on a publié elle s'appelle
pourquoi y a-t-il de Corée dans cette
vidéo on se plonge davantage dans
l'historique de cette guerre des deux
Corée en tout cas c'est la fin de cette
vidéo sur les frontières évidemment
cette vidéo elle n'est pas exhaustive il
y a plein d'autres frontières ou autres
qui mériteraient d'être traité et
évidemment là aussi on n'a pas traité
toute la dimension politique sociale ou
autre on s'est concentré surtout sur la
dimension géographique dans le cadre de
cette vidéo mais si jamais vous voulez
prolonger le sujet d'un point de vue
géographique notamment et bien elle a
mis doc seven a fait pas mal de vidéos
en France sur le sujet il y a quelques
années pour la petite histoire faut
savoir que Doc seven c'est vraiment lui
qui m'a fait décoller sur Youtube au
départ j'avais très peu d'abonnés il
m'avait donné ma chance en me laissant
présenter ma chaîne en intro de l'une de
ces vidéos et ça avait fait décoller la
chaîne à l'époque tout ça pour dire
qu'il a fait trois quatre vidéos sur le
sujet sur d'autres frontières donc je
vous invite à aller voir le lien est
directement en description n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner mais c'est pas encore le
cas prenez soin de vous prenez soin de
nos proches et puis on se dit du coup à
très vite